nur und erst sind zwei worte die von
deutsch lernen häufig verwechselt werden
der grund dafür ist im englischen kann
man sie beide mit only übersetzen aber
im deutschen gibt es zwei versionen
der unterschied hat damit zu tun ob
etwas wiederholt werden kann oder ob
etwas abgeschlossen ist
nur beschreibt zustände die nur ein
einziges mal passieren die nicht
wiederholt werden können
erst beschreibt einen offenen zustand
wenn ich etwas erst einmal gemacht habe
dann kann es sein dass ich das noch
öfter machen kann wenn ich es nur einmal
gemacht habe heißt das dass sich das nie
wieder machen kann
wir haben einige beispiele für euch
gedreht einige szenen und die seht ihr
jetzt
ich bin 13 tage in berlin sie bleibt
noch länger hier
ich bin nur drei tage in berlin danach
fährt sie wieder nach hause
ich bin erst 20 jahre alt sie wird
wahrscheinlich noch älter ich habe nur
ein tennis kleid an
sie hat es keine anderen klamotten dabei
ich habe erst einen keks gegessen
sie möchte noch mehr kekse essen ich
habe nur noch einen keks jetzt gibt es
keinen mehr
ich bin erst einmal mit diesem fahrrad
gefahren
es könnte sein dass sie noch öfters
damit fährt ich bin nur einmal mit
diesem fahrrad gefahren
sie wird nie wieder damit fahren ist es
viel zu groß jetzt könnt ihr das thema
selbst noch weiter üben in unserer app
sie lenkt rentier die szene nochmal
angucken
ihr könnt dabei auch eure eigene
aussprache trainieren und ihr könnt die
unter tel anklicken da erhaltet ihr
wichtige grammatik informationen und
übersetzungen
schaut es euch mal an hier geht es zur
ceiling und hier könnt ihr easy german
abonnieren
und hier kommt gerade ein neues flugzeug
in berlin an
bis zur nächsten woche auch okay ich
mache nur ganz knapp